[Music]
ukraine's army is readying itself for
further conflict with russia holding
drills near annexed crimea in case its
eastern neighbour invades
britain has delivered fresh military
equipment including anti-tank weapons to
kiev a move russia calls a provocation
as the prime minister issued this
warning to the kremlin
if
russia
were to make any kind of incursion into
ukraine of any
uh on any scale whatever
i think that that would be a
disaster for
not just for ukraine but for russia it
would disaster for the world
the white house is on a damage control
mission the u.s president seeking to
clarify comments he made on wednesday
that a minor incursion into ukraine
might result in a lesser response from
the west than a full-scale invasion
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border that is an invasion
but it will be met with severe and
coordinated economic response that i've
discussed in detail with our allies as
well as laid out very clearly for
president putin
but there is no doubt let there be no
doubt at all that if putin makes this
choice russia will pay a heavy price
from berlin america's top diplomat
stressed the west stood united he meets
with his russian counterpart in geneva
on friday but with russia's core demand
an end to nato expansion the one area
where nato won't budge those talks won't
be easy
sergey karaganov is among the more
hawkish viewpoints that you'll find in
moscow and he's tight with the kremlin's
inner circle
a nato expansion
was
it was a cancer cancer which was
introduced into the body of
of
of the subcontinent we will have to
heal it
by deploying a hundred thousand troops
we've needed even more you don't heal by
force i am sorry
you need sometimes to heal a cancer
you have to
go for an operation
that message has sunk in the latest
opinion polls showing that most russians
believe it is nato in the u.s not russia
who were responsible for tensions over
ukraine
but it's another question whether
they're prepared to send in their young
men to fight
vladimir putin has made an art form out
of keeping people guessing and that is
just the way he likes it but there is
one issue on timing which does seem
reasonable and that is that china is
about to host the winter olympics now
the last time they hosted the games was
in 2008 when russia invaded georgia and
given the fact that he is interested in
maintaining good relations with the
chinese leader it does seem unlikely
that president putin would do that again
both sides for now say they'll keep on
with diplomacy and dialogue and russia
still insists it has no intention of
invading ukraine even if most in the
west don't believe it
dinah magnay sky news moscow